we didn't have a business plan no
investors just the three of us we
basically jumped in head first went
surfing on a giant dangerous wave and
couldn't fall we were all friends and
would spend a lot of our off time
together get up at 4:00 a.m. go surfing
get back to the city by 9:00 a.m. go to
work it just translated really well for
us into this lifestyle I think when
people consider surf is a very relaxed
loose soft roll out of bed throw on go
check the waves and we don't live those
lifestyles we live in apartments in New
York City and we roll out of bed into
the most fashionable city in the world
and you got to look sharp you got to
feel great and our clothing epitomizes
that the first place we looked was a
gallery it was beautiful old cobblestone
street in Soho and once we had the space
it was literally like blinders you know
we were just full steam ahead
we quit our jobs we would work 12 to 18
hours a day seven days a week night time
I would DJ Josh would bartend
Colin had some side art Direction gigs
was fantastic looks really good colors
work out perfect let's create this
community of like-minded people that are
interested in this lifestyle that we
wanted to create
so a buyer from a beautiful store in
Japan was in New York and asked a friend
of ours what school in New York what's
new in New York our friend said go check
out Saturdays and this guy came by and
just kind of understood it right away
they said if you guys make t-shirts who
love to carry them okay
yes of course and so we created
something over the weekend and that was
the seed money to put t-shirts in our
own store a year after that is when
another department store from the u.s.
asked if we made an entire collection at
a core and we said yes and then we
designed it and that got us to the next
step
spring 2011 first collection that we
launched changed our store from being
private label and multi brand to just
completely mono brand
that was a solid three years making
everything work without taking anything
from the company and be able to continue
to see you sees opportunities exciting
and humbling and huge growth personally
in terms of what you can put yourself
through and what you can achieve when
you have no one else to rely on except
your two business partners who were
jumped in with you so make it happen in
there and it would look fine I disagree
I think that threes worked really well
for us it's never to battle between two
people there's always a tiebreaker what
do you think that I've never had two
girlfriends at once but it's like it's
intent or brother or brothers it was
exactly we can look at something and
almost always agree whether it should be
a color style or fifth embroidered right
yeah it's cool just blow the pocket the
feeling really onion quilting makes it
uniquely our own you know yeah for each
of the three of us have probably would
have been helpful to have some sort of
training but there's something really
honest about what we make because it
really is how we dress and how we feel
this is our Crosby a very classic piece
in the collection for a very long time
definitely it takes the three of us to
create whatever it is Saturday's is a
few Kiwi tailors in Japan started to
support the brand and get behind it the
three of us we're like we have to go
there seemed Tokyo and the proximity to
the ocean the people that are working
but then also loving being in the water
doing the same kind of lifestyle things
that we were doing we've looked at each
other like let's do this let's work in
Japan
Tokio really gave us momentum to see
where this brand can go who's up there
and top moments of the Saturday's
lifespan so far from you we love the
people we love the experience we had we
thought the culture part of our DNA is
being able to be outside be outdoors
experience all these different elements
that's what happened in Japan and that's
what happened in Australia we're
adventurous and we want to get out all
of those things lead to our aesthetic we
launched our new slug last line Sasha we
have these moments a whiff like almost
pinch ourselves and we're like how did
we get to this moment
[Music]
for us it's been a really aggressive
ride fast-paced and intense but it's
been so rewarding because of that and
that's what inspires me to kind of get
up and go every day it's like it's
another beautiful day and craziest city
in the world
[Music]